[Music]
hey
[Applause]
com
de frontier in this competition where you
tennis with the English
- slim
[Applause]
to strikes and 15 laps ok
of his sex tics
[Music]
no no no
[Applause]
[Music]
I know
efe
[Music]
freedom in their countries
lewis
[Music]
ah
tomorrow
but no
no
ah
[Music]
i
e
[Music]
i
I only have been
that  it's what i want
robert no cost and tall rooms
i was dying
[Music]
no
and more
[Music]
wright the design of m
s
[Music]
smooth
as the car
[Music]
or not
i
yes
[  Music]
h
[Music]
hello doctor lynn
everything
[Music]
is this line full
son
and
yes
isern
[Music]
had
[Applause]
station
three years ago
[Applause]
[Music]
[  Applause]
manuel state
[Music]
if I market you
ah
[Music]